i had to do a double take when i
realized you were the same person who
played um
david mack and city of lies yes yes yes
yes
really good work in both films thank you
very much i appreciate that yeah that
was a very different role
we actually had the screening last night
at too short studio in los angeles
with brad furman we had a little release
party with some of the cast and uh that
was a great film and a great product to
be a part of it
uh i'm glad i needed to do a double take
i guess i did my job
100 i could totally dive in on that one
but one of the things
jumping into stowaway since they have
such a limited time one of the things
that i really responded to is the fact
that the film doesn't really have a
villain
uh the villain is just the situation
they've been dealt um and i found that
very refreshing can you sort of talk
about that
aspect of this the script yeah i think
that's what makes the script super
special it's a human piece you know and
the elements at play are kind of
if you want to call them the the the
antagonist you know if there's even that
um
just really dealing with human emotion
human interaction and dealing with the
stakes of a situation
it's kind of great it's similar to films
that i love like um you know castaways
of the world and you know elements of i
am legend
and so when looking at this script i
said you know this is something when i
you know such a human piece
and it's about living in that truth and
you literally are on this roller coaster
ride when you're reading it from the
beginning to the end just on the script
alone of like what's going to happen
you know where is this going to go
because you're not expecting some alien
to come in and intercept the process
it's just kind of you know dealing with
the elements at play which is space
it's primarily four actors in a room
debating
the moral quandary of what they've been
dealt
um can you sort of talk about the fact
that it's really just the four of you
the whole movie
um and what day did you get sick of
somebody i'm joking
now it's kind of like a stage play you
know i come from the theater so for me
it felt like i was in a contained space
like i was back in theater school but no
i didn't get sick of anybody daniel day
kim
and kendrick and tony collette you know
definitely beasts
individually in their own right but um
it was it was an incredible
intimate experience for me and you don't
get to play in those type of confines in
those type of arenas very often usually
you're surrounded by
other elements locations and and dealing
with
people randoms running on the set by
accident or having to cut because of a
plane
but this set was very controlled and
very contained which
really helps the performance at times
which is definitely a rarity as you
don't get that
you know very often in the uh the new
cgi
green screen age that we're all in
completely um
my he's probably my last thing for you i
read that you actually slept
in the place that you sleep in the movie
sort of mentally figure out like what
that environment was like can you can
you sort of share
um your motivation for doing that and
what you learned from doing that
wow i don't know how you got that
information but that's incredible but
yes
a lot of time in my preparation process
i tend to immerse myself before i even
go to camera
so for this project i've never been to
space obviously
and so i wanted to really understand
what it felt like to be claustrophobic
in a small space
you know what michael went through in
that process so not only did i sleep in
the space every single morning my call
time was at seven
so i show up set at five and i would
spend the extra two hours sleeping
in the compartment on set i actually uh
in this in the room that i had me
holding in
i had all the lights off i actually put
black construction paper all along my
windows and poked little dots on them to
emulate stars
so as much as i can be in darkness as
much as i can and really felt small
and feel small and michael's a little
introvert and i wanted to really be able
to
you know have that authentic experience
flowing through my blood
from the moment i you know arrived on
set and that was something that joe
penna and the crew
in germany allowed me to do you know
pre-covert of course
and i i do believe it definitely helped
because i felt aches and pains every
morning
which was kind of nice because you know
being in that stowaway place
for a couple of hours or two hours i
think it was you know you're definitely
gonna feel those aches and pains which i
think helped my process at least
um and hopefully they'll show it on
screen it did congrats on the movie
and thank you so much for your time hey
stephen thank you man i gotta see one of
those toys in real life i want one